The Prompt for my conversation or for
this conversation has to do with a uh a
recent poll that was taken uh that uh
Liz Nolan Brown who we'll be talking to
in a second wrote up for reason this was
done by Newsweek but uh the finding was
kind of stunning I got a lot of play 44
of Millennials want to make misgendering
a crime let's talk about this poll uh
Liz that you wrote up I think last week
for reason uh 44 of Millennials want to
make misgendering a crime and let me
just read a bit uh uh you write younger
Millennials were most likely to support
criminal penalties for misgendering with
44 of 24 to 30 25 to 34 year old
respondents in favor and just 31 saying
misgendering should not be a crime uh
and then you look a little bit older and
you know the 25 to 34 year olds that
includes some gen Z so it's uh you know
Millennial and gen Z but then some 38 of
35 to 44 year old respondents said it
should be a crime while 35 percent
disagreed some 33 of 18 to 24 year old
respondents which would be gen Z said it
should be a crime while 48 disagreed so
you have you know Liz to you the best of
your
hypothesizing you know what is going on
that 44 of 25 to 34 year old respondents
think that misgendering somebody should
be a crime
it's it's they're not thinking about it
they're not thinking it through that's
my that's my most I guess hopeful
interpretation
um is you know people are people are
very concerned with trans rights these
days they're very
um a lot of people you know are very
rightfully think that you should you
know respect people's pronouns respect
people's gender that they consider
themselves and they want to signal that
so when you're asking a survey like
should it be a crime sure why not you
know my hopeful I I think that's nuts
but I may be a prison I may be a prison
abolitionist but I think this should be
a crime yeah I so my my like hopeful
interpretation is that people answer
survey questions a lot of times based on
a sort of desirability bias of trying to
say what they think is right and this is
a way to signal that you think it is
wrong to misgender people
but there's no actual proposal attached
to this right there's no like you know
like here's what the criminal penalties
would be here's how much you know time
people would spend in prison or what
they'd have to pay here's how it would
be enforced there's no discussion about
all the all the you know unintended
consequences
um and things like that so I I hope that
you know if if this was an actual
proposal people were actually discussing
it the support would be a lot lower than
um you know than in a poll where it's
just like hey is this you know where
it's more answered almost as if like hey
is this bad people say yeah
because unfortunately we do have you
know a we are in an era where people
think that like anything bad should be a
crime sort of at least before they think
it through
what about uh Gene what do you think is
there you know and this poll you know
was done by Newsweek
um the data is not available online I
look around for we don't even know the
exact questioning you know the wording
of the question so all of that those are
serious caveats but it seems to comport
with a general attitude among you know a
large chunk of younger people say people
under 30 or under 35 towards
um not putting up with speech they find
uh
ugly or or uncomfortable what you know
what's your read of something like this
well it really jumped out at me
is that the Gen the the purely gen Z
that 18 to 24 year olds who are actually
less likely to say that they thought it
should be a crime so yeah I would love
to see that data because that that's an
interesting result
um it might suggest that maybe a corner
has been turned um and gen Z is like
yeah of course I don't want to misgender
people but no it should be a crime maybe
they have witnessed enough cancel
culture that they're over it
um but you know because a few years ago
the data we had we have suggest you know
it's much more linear that that the
younger you get the more likely people
would would say no we would need to
restrict speech the other big political
thing that informed I think or at least
you know the millennial politics like
aside from the whole war on terror stuff
was was like the gay marriage battles
because that was you know just when we
were in high school and college and that
and you know in our early 20s that was
sort of dominating politics um all the
different fights in the state and all of
that and uh and really driving a lot of
a lot of why why the political
metabolism so I think yeah that was very
important one thing that's one thing
that's uh you know amazing and Gene's
book goes into this quite a bit that you
know the younger you are the more likely
you are to be completely comfortable
with all kinds of sexual orientation and
you know particularly something like gay
marriage
um uh Liz what was it that you know kind
of sensitized you or your cohort to that
as an important thing and and I guess a
leading question here how much of it was
it was something that you you and your
friends took for granted that your
parents were kind of like hemming and
Hong about
that it was a way of separating you from
your parents or one's parents
no I think a lot of our parents we're a
little bit opposed but came around about
the issue during during that time like I
know that my parents um sort of were
like kind of a knee-jerk like well no
they shouldn't and then like when they
thought about it for three seconds they
were like actually I don't know why I'm
a post and they they changed their mind
over the course of you know a very short
time um as as the issue was in the
spotlight and and so I think that
actually that was you know it wasn't it
wasn't I don't think a generational
issue per se
um I I think it did you know it it did
matter a lot that a lot of us had just
come up with with knowing gay people in
a way that were out in a way that like
other Generations didn't so it just
seemed like of course you know this is
this is the thing that should be allowed
but um you know on the other on the
other hand it was also sort of just
foisted upon us
because we're really using that well
both parties were really using that as a
wedge issue and a get out the vote yeah
I mean and it's worth pointing out sort
of you couldn't ignore it yeah that
people like Bill Clinton certainly but
Hillary Clinton even Barack Obama when
he was elected president was openly
against gay marriage against marriage
equality
um so the the speed with which these old
you know kind of uh certainties die is
well you know it's amazing and there's
definitely you know you can see a lot of
that sort of the anger at the system
alive and well amongst Millennials and
gen Z depending on you know where you
are and what the protest is about like I
mean we saw a ton of that during during
a lot of the you know racial Justice
protests in in 2020 and and again before
that back in you know 2014 2015 so I
think I think that sort of anger at the
system is still very much alive and and
well today
I um one of the things I find
fascinating is that in the 60s and I
have spent much of my professional
career trying to be the quizling of the
baby boom generation like I I want to
collaborate with Gen X and with
Millennials and gen Z to sink the
Boomers to get rid of them I think you
know the Boomers tend to be full of
themselves or we are full of ourselves
and all of that kind of stuff but it's
interesting to me that in the 60s
generation of what came after there was
a move to build alternative systems and
alternative communities or to challenge
the system very forthrightly so you you
know people move to communes people
created alternative uh corporations
alternative schools uh the Black
Panthers are one example of this in the
civil rights movement and also the LGBT
uh you know the the gay and lesbian
movement the Gay Liberation movement
women's lib was like you we are
going to do our own thing and we're
going to exit and that's how we reform
things and what strikes me as a
meaningful change now is that many of
the people and you know on campuses and
Millennials they are actually
petitioning the system
rather than leaving it or even altering
it it's and it's almost as if they
believe on some deep-seated level that
the system is there and it is responsive
to them and it has been because when we
look at the system if the system is
America it is much better in terms of
race in terms of class in terms of
gender and sexual orientation and I
wonder if we've kind of reached a limit
maybe of where you know the the
Grievances that are being put in front
of the system now the system can't
really do much about that that was an
excerpt from my interview with Liz Nolan
Brown of reason and Gene twangy author
most recently of generations if you want
to see another excerpt go here and if
you want to see the full conversation go
here and make sure to come back every
Thursday at 1 pm eastern time when
reason is talking to people with
something very interesting to say that
you definitely want to hear